yeah i just i disagree with that i don't
think i know there's this whole thing of
you know women are
you know generally more emotional than
men
but
this whole thing of being like when a
girl goes
oh he made me crazy or he made her crazy
i just think that's just massive
[ __ ] like you are
you're control you're in control of your
own actions and you can you can leave
the environment you can leave the
situation i i agree
i like i agree with you like i think in
an ideal world like you should leave but
that doesn't always happen because i
just think guys can't use that excuse oh
well she just made me crazy so i decked
her in the throat like guys oh but i
wasn't talking about decking in the
throat that's like when i
when i thought crazy i just thought like
she's always asking where i am or like
she's looking through my phone that's
what i was thinking i wasn't oh no i
never i would never crazy like she's
like thrown [ __ ] cuz oh no i would never
never never in a million years advocate
like that that's something okay
is your ability to pick though yeah it
is 100
oh no i was going to say i would jump in
here and say literally i was like
literally i could have kissed you right
then
that um that that is equally what i
would say the red flag for me if a guy
says his girlfriend is like specifically
psycho [ __ ] those are literal words
i've heard before always it's always the
guys that cheat it's always always
that's always nice
but it's always and this is the thing
man does something wrong woman holds him
accountable woman is then a psycho [ __ ]
and like that isn't the trend sometimes
sometimes the one thing i would say
is like
the i so i agree with the first part of
what you said i would disagree with the
latter part about to do with sometimes
it's the woman's fault if someone or
like is the person's fault if they're
being abused i would say for sure do you
think it's their fault for picking them
like if it's the same pattern for sure i
would say that sometimes people have a
pattern of picking abuses but i think a
lot of the time people who have been
raised in abusive
surroundings it's just that thing
because that is what the and i think
sometimes i think people sometimes
people are really deceptive there have
been cases of marrying someone who as
soon as they're married they completely
i've just found there's like if there's
a pattern of behavior like a lot of
times like girls won't talk about what
they did first
so like yeah maybe he like did something
but like
that i never would advocate for a guy to
hit well
yeah
even
threatening a guy with a wife a knife oh
or something like that that's what i was
thinking okay okay yeah yeah that's all
right that's what i was thinking like
like if if a girl
is your thing shut up
why would i but then we're talking about
uh but then we're talking about a woman
who's instigating abuse because they're
being abusive
but i think why do we assume that like
the woman like she could have started it
okay yeah she could have by being
abusive in the first place right in case
we're not talking about domestic abuse
victims but we're talking about someone
in a in a right equally toxic and
abusive relationship i think it can be
both i think yeah that's definitely a
thing but i think it's dangerous
territory territory to wander into the
well maybe she maybe it's justified
maybe she deserved it and i think or
maybe he deserved it maybe he deserves
yeah yeah yeah this is also another
thing of of women that was a really good
documentary on the bbc i mean i think
you have to question like people that
bring that stuff forward like either way
like if they're going to press charges
or something they have to
like question them yeah you have to you
of course you have to look at all the
evidence yeah i guess i just come from a
standpoint of
i've seen women who have been in those
relationships yeah and nine times out of
ten more than nine times out of ten 99
of the time
it's genuinely that you know they've not
held a knife to their guy's throat and
again i think this is where the physical
dominance comes into a relationship of
like i am intrinsically always going to
feel more vulnerable around like take
you for example all right you are way
taller than me okay physically okay
regardless of my strength my strength
training historically
you could overpower me so easily like
and i think guys know that in a
relationship with a woman you're an
idiot if you don't and women are aware
of that in a relationship and i think it
it starts to wander into dangerous
territory when we start to say um
did they do something to deserve this
and where do we draw the line with that
do we draw the line with that with rape
did they do something to deserve this
did they instigate it in some way but
like that's you have to like the police
have to also do you know because you
can't give someone the power to just and
i think it's actually the same thing in
society like you have to question people
when they bring something forward
because you don't ever want to give
someone this like the power to ruin
someone's reputation with just accusing
them of something that could have been
completely false there has to be
evidence yeah you you have to
investigate it i guess my point is where
does that line of questioning come from
and where does that bleed into society
does it come from a point of because i
intrinsically disbelieve you because all
women are trying to ruin men's lives or
does it come from a point of i need to
know this evidence because i'm a
prosecutor well it's innocent until
proven guilty yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you realize like society favors women
like they say believe all women even
though women be crazy
like no i'm saying like there are crazy
girls that lie about [ __ ] and like ruin
men's lives like they go to jail or even
if they don't do that like a girl can
ruin a guy's reputation with just an
accusation okay but look at look at the
amount of men okay within england i
think it's something like one percent
of uh of of reported uh sexual assault
crimes get get taken
uh to be prosecuted by this by the cps
by the crown prosecution service it's
something like one percent right because
you need evidence yeah yeah yeah and and
they ask for very substantial
very very substantial evidence in order
to prosecute it because they're like
that's a lot of money to invest in it i
can understand what but it's hard to
prove that yeah and then they also then
from taking it to court it's such a low
percentage that actually get proven true
and a lot of the time it's because but
you're you're assuming but you're
assuming right now like your automatic
assumption is that all those people are
like telling the truth right like all
the because you don't know what
percentage of the people that came
forward with that stuff were telling the
truth and what we're lying and i'm not
saying like we know either way but like
you can't know
no you can't but i would equally say
that i think we view this so completely
differently than like any other crime if
someone said i was burgled you don't see
you don't see guys going um you or you
don't smile you're saying like well you
know innocent until proven jesus
his fingerprints were found at the crime
scene there is video evidence here of
him doing it yeah
innocent until proven guilty no no i
don't also i would like to say i don't
know a single woman who has ever lied
about being assaulted but i know so many
women who okay can i
so i will say two things i've got a
story
personally about a woman lying about me
um but the other thing i was going to
say is that like it it you are right in
those stats but it's because sexual
assault is very hard to prove with
evidence like they they apply the same
standard of there has to be substantial
evidence in other cases like for example
like do you know how many people get
convicted for stealing cars
it's like less than one percent because
it's so hard to prove because once a car
is gone it's gone yeah so i don't i i
completely hear what you're saying but
it's like it's not
it's because it and unfortunately it's
very hard to prove
um
when i was back in training
in drama school
and
first term you know everyone's having
fun and everything right and i remember
there was this girl
who we were like flirting in class and
everything and stuff was happening
anyway
she asked me this was friday she was
like oh you're going to so-and-so's
party tonight and i was like yeah she's
like okay i'll see you there so i was
like all right cool i was like maybe
she's feeding me or this
go to the party i see her for a bit and
then i don't really see her throughout
the night
we're leaving the party right i'm
leaving i'm about to go home
and i see her outside with her housemate
and she's like oh kit um she's like
where are you how you doing i was like
yeah i'm good you have a good time yeah
she's like what are you doing now i'm
just gonna get on the night bus home
she's like oh why don't you
stay with me at mine i live around the
corner
i was like okay i was like i hadn't
really seen her throughout the whole
party so i was like i didn't think
anything of it
so we get back to hers and she
one of my friends was a roommate of hers
and he wasn't staying there that night
so i was just like okay i'll just stay
in his room like because i really see
that i didn't think anything of it
and then she was like oh
um why don't you stay in my bed i was
like
all right
cool so i go to the toilet
i come out
she's basically stripped naked in the
bed and she's like oh come give me a
cuddle i was like all right
so i was like okay so i kind of stripped
down to our boxes giving her naked card
and stuff but obviously you know i just
started kissing the back of her neck
started trying initiating stuff and she
wasn't really kind of reciprocating i
was like oh like
i was like do you know what you got
it wasn't okay
continue she was like
i was i was like oh do you not want to
like you're not tempted whatever and she
was like oh she was like basically like
i just um there's this guy that i kind
of started seeing i really want to see
how it goes
and i was like
okay
and i was like uh i thought she was
joking i was like oh really she's like
no yeah like i just kind of really like
i don't want to mess it up or anything
so i was like okay and i'll be honest
like i was pissed off because i felt
massively led on i was like i was going
home why did my own business and you
invited me back to yours or whatever
and you basically asked me to give you a
naked cuddle but i was like you know
fine whatever
turned around went to sleep in the
morning i left i didn't even say
anything
fast forward two years
i'm on holiday with a group of my
friends a really close female friend of
mine and she goes we're in spain and she
goes kip
you know i'm gonna say the name in case
they watch this they're like you know um
so and so i was like oh yeah she was
like you know because something happened
between you and her in first year i was
like yeah she was like you like what
happened so i told a story i just told
you she was like yeah that makes
that like
definitely makes more sense for who i
know that you are and i was like why
what did you hear
apparently she had gone around telling
everyone that i tried to force myself
onto her
b man
that's what happened mate
i cannot tell you the [ __ ] rage oh my
god your audacity
and i found this out two years did you
say something to her no
has anything like that ever has that
ever happened to you guys
and i was like imagine if that came out
now
yeah that would ruin my everything right
that like i know it's purely anecdotal
but the thing is and i'll be honest
she's not even a bad person like she's
not a psycho girl she's like a regular
pretty girl
right
and i just didn't expect that
and i found that out two years later
like you just wouldn't so i'm not saying
this happens all the time but what i'm
trying to say is that the reason i
shared that story is because
it's not the crazy girl who you think
yeah she'd make out and because she was
like your average girl and she was just
saying now she may have not meant it
maliciously at the time but that could
have been me and asked massively well
and nobody questioned her because like
that's what i'm like nobody said okay
well how did that happen you don't like
ask those questions well she's just
spreading this like around like
that's what she told the girls
apparently well it sounds like um
thank you by the way for sharing that
because stuff like that as well is like
it's very difficult as someone who has
been through abuse sexual assault
multiple times it's very difficult to
share that but i can also appreciate
it's very difficult to share with
someone with a group with the internet
with whoever like someone accusing you
of this
um so thank you but also just being
honest
but
it sounds like this this female friend
who came to you
did the right thing but also it sounds
like people had
concerns or at least were kind of going
did this actually happen well especially
because like in the in the two years i
didn't hear anything about it and i'd
you know been involved with other people
so
like i don't know how much of it went
around and stuff but um
so i heard something it's mad i had
someone
on the
at my college i just found this out like
a month or two ago that he was telling
everyone we hooked up and i was like
i've never even kissed you like i'm so
confused oh [ __ ] and i was like
no but this is what happened like he
snapped me i remembered him like trying
like snapping me and i literally told
him he's like can i come over and i was
like no and he's like why and i was like
because i don't want to sleep with you
like and he was like oh thanks for
making that clear
and i was like
and so now i'm like this is like four
years later i'm like
what what did he say
but i don't know
it's people are weird
i've had that happen before with guys
which is quite funny i
me and my friend were talking about this
before me and me and me and a female
friend me and a female friend who did
end up hooking up me and this girl and
the whole male group was salty because
they had all tried moves on me and i was
like nah i'm not interested you guys are
pagans
i was like it's not like if it was true
i'd be like yeah like you would have
heard about it probably from me like
like really
do you know why guys say that though
because like in our social group
like guys we were like
for example your name is emily i said
like
yeah i saw you talking to emily you beat
emily yeah like on that spot there
you can't say
you can't edit it but it's hard to be
like
nothing happens
it's easier to realize
no but this guy i didn't even like i was
saying that's not okay though i had
never even hung out with him one-on-one
that's what i was confused
i think it's jay he's always chatting
[ __ ] he's always like yeah yeah like i'm
such a player as long as you give me a
five as long as you give me a five star
review like honestly for real as long as
you were like yeah and she was great i'm
like all right to be fair i respect the
hustle
well i think it was because
though i find this out years later
because i was interested in his friend
and so but his friend like wouldn't talk
to me because he said he thought and i
was like no
he yeah
he's like i don't like him but i respect
the play
i was like what the [ __ ] well yeah no i
have to agree because that was like one
of the most clear i have ever been to a
dude like cause sometimes you're nice
but i wasn't even like no i was just
like look never
like you slept with like five of my
friends i don't want to be six like what
are you talking about
but yeah i have to agree with them um
going back to the fact that girls
girls do you pick that crazy guys
because i feel like girls they just they
just love taking all the red flags they
they see the red flags
this is the first date and then they're
like nah like
it was just a fluke or something and the
next few you know he's now slapping you
up but then you saw this like since the
first minute of the day
kind of thing but then
but they're going back to like say if
um guys are picking crazy girls i feel
like most i've been in a situation where
when i first met the girl she was she
was completely fine everything was
stable
and then say three months in
i don't know what happened like what did
you do that's the real question no
what i told you
i've just been paid me the whole time
but just because nothing's changed
and this goes back to the fact where
um when i was asking oh like would it
matter if
um
he wanted to see you every two weeks if
you start from two weeks because like
what i realized is a lot of girls would
not want that and then all of a sudden
they start acting crazy like oh you're
definitely doing this
i've been doing this since the beginning
i don't know